she's going hungry for Hamas yes Sex in
the City Star Cynthia Nixon taking part
in a 5-day hunger strike but only for
two days the actress is demanding a
permanent ceasefire in Gaza she says we
are here hunger striking just a sort of
mirror to Biden the kind of deprivation
that is happening in Gaza and how he has
it within his power to make a ceasefire
happen which is all complete nonsense
which you hear about the uh one of the
hostages little boy who was not even
given food by the win worker yeah we can
talk about that later but Greg let me
ask you a two-day hunger strike is
really just a fast it is it is how can
you tell the difference between her and
all the other actresses in Hollywood
they don't eat I mean they they they
that's what they do to get ready for a
part hunger
strikes they they hunger strikes have to
be open-ended right you can't just like
that's how you leverage uh your your
your health against the the opponent you
don't put a cap on it although I am
hungry striking right now for at least
an hour to protest against all the
unnecessary stories featuring Taylor
Swift I think that we have to have
enough of that so at six o'clock I will
be back in the Green Room you should
always strike with something that
matters to you celebrities need to go on
an attention strike no frothy
pronouncements no texting tweeting
displays of virtue signaling that will
mean something Jessica you're a fan of
the show I know a lot of us are but this
is stupid it is stupid I am not a fan of
cynthian Nixon's politics I think
they're hot garbage and this morning
Chuck Schumer gave um quite you were
covering it on Newsroom um an amazing
address about the rise in anti-Semitism
it was remarkable and something that was
really powerful that he said was that
anti-Semitism isn't coming primarily
from the far right but from quote people
that most liberal Jewish Americans felt
previously were their ideological
ideological fellow Travelers and you
know Cynthia Nixon hasn't said anything
anything about the women the Jewish
women who were targeted no she hasn't
said a word no brutality but but you
know I love that she says that she's
going on a hunger strike to trigger the
Israel Hamas peace as if anything she
would do would trigger anything as it
relates to Israel and Hamas but I think
the most significant thing that maybe
she's unaware of is that Hamas throws
gays off buildings all right and she
thinks that you know putting her health
in danger might trigger peace I mean
it's so ridiculous she knows nothing
about the history I'm not going to waste
time but this is ridiculous Jesse final
word did you effort her for your show no
but we're having Johnny deliver pasta to
her house just to tempt her because this
isn't a hunger strike it's a fast and
fasting is good for you h a two-day fast
has many medical benefits I'm
considering doing it myself although
some people say it's actually bad for
your health so I don't really know what
I'm going to do maybe you need an effort
and nutrition IED analysis yeah I do
know this I do know that no one bad for
you no let's just go to commercial hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else